hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to once
upon time there's a movie called the
neverending story and they kick in my
opinion it was one of the best family
films ever it had great atmosphere of
creative characters a complex story
that's a real legitimate drama so when I
heard there was another movie I got
excited as hell I love the first one I
could wait to see another one it blues
[Music]
I mean what a cheap follow-up for a film
series that was so gripping and even
challenging for younger viewers never
Nate's story to gave us a really
watered-down half-assed version of its
predecessor what a disappointment so
let's see why the neverending story
should have ended first of all I should
point out that none of the original cast
is in this movie the characters are the
same but none of the same actors play
them I guess you could argue that the
actors were too old by that time but if
Hermione's breasts are still in high
school then I'll believe any age then
throwing me so our first big replacement
is the overly imaginative Bastion who's
played by jonathan brandis yeah you
remember the hallucinating nut ball from
sidekicks this is kid ever play someone
mentally stable now granted the one
downside of the first film was the actor
who played Bastion he was kind of a wimp
and really annoying but that all changes
here in this film he's really a wimp and
kind of annoying so I guess it balances
out on top of that it's just not that
great of performance I mean it's better
than the first bill but mm-hmm yes
don't act like you don't see me are you
talking about you've been ignoring me
since the beginning don't act like you
don't know why I'm here is it the job
that Brandis kid about you know he
committed suicide Oh fine I'll address
this in 2003 Jonathan brain has
committed suicide any death is tragic
and this one is no exception
and you know what his acting wasn't
half-bad I remember him on Seaquest and
ladybugs and stuff even though the film
choices weren't always great he usually
did okay he's a relatively decent actor
I just don't think he did especially
well in this movie it's not his fault I
mean it's a horribly written character
he's a dumbass as you'll see in a few
moments so just to make it clear I
nothing against jonathan brandis as a
person then is that good gee that was
awkward yeah see you got a an elephant
so we see him bashing in this women
class where hi speedo where his teacher
calls my speedo again and wants him to
try out on the big board hello humorous
clown shorts we're gonna start with the
high board but it turns out that Bastion
is afraid of heights and has trouble
confronting his fears nobody said that
the diving and diving class I got a
cramp
I went back there Bastion sorry coach so
he doesn't jump off as he goes home to a
disappointed father played by your
standard Alan Thicke impersonator
well the dressing is common courtesy
Bastian I mean I something you oughta
learn by the way look at that old rag
you're wearing he has a point there
Bastian you do so look like an outward
star fighter pilot well made it oh you
need me again no I'm good hmm Sebastian
goes upstairs and pout about how his
relationship with his dad isn't as good
as it used to be
Hey just a random question here um
remember how in the last film it ended
with him flying a luck dragon over the
city chasing down some bullies and
exposing a never-before-seen creature in
front of hundreds um are we just never
gonna address that didn't make the news
or anything flying what dragon eats
children that I never make the front
page
well surely someone must our Twitter
about it
sebastian goes to the only returning
actor in this movie the librarian as
he's trying to find a book about how not
to be a pussy i look in my section on
courage but he suddenly hears a
whispering voice from an old familiar
book what casques too much of you but
it's the neverending story i've already
read it but if you ever read a book
twice books change each time you read
them for example if you read The
Velveteen Rabbit again it's really about
Nazis I really want to read it again no
no no no me borrow it please no not you
stop don't come back so his Bastian goes
to read the book again he finds it truly
is a little different
[Music]
well that's inviting he finds that the
orange symbol on the front can actually
be taken off now but not only that he
can enter the fucking book Fantasia
[Music]
yeah I just praise my Fantasia to fasten
the annoying celebrity cameos would be
to roof so while Bastion admires how
model age Fantasia looks we come to the
hideout of our villain who lives in the
terrifying castle cliche I came as fast
aside I guess she had to put her face on
this evil vilnius is aida also known as
the emptiness yeah cuz it doesn't sound
anything like the nothing doesn't I
don't know why she looks like Jessica
Rabbit while skydiving but I do know she
has a diabolical plan to destroy Bastion
as well as Fantasia every time the
earthling uses Oren to make a wish my
new invention makes him lose a memory
with each wish the liquid in this head
forms a memory ball what happens when
the earthling has lost all of his
memories the beaker at the bottom is
full and the Earthlings head is empty oh
please you can show them biodome and
they'll have the same effect so they
either since her henchmen Italy to great
Bastion and try to trick him into making
some wishes you have re it fulfills all
of your wishes so Beijing admires Silver
City not to Mexico as he looks around
and admires just how weird it is
[Music]
everything seems fine pinching fine fine
maybe for burning man is pretty fucked
up to me the VINs Aida sends down her D
silly-looking minions to spread chaos
throughout the town
now you think about Leo
yeah Kakadu she has a point why don't
you just wish them away just wish
hi this makes no sense I mean I know if
he makes a wish he loses a memory but he
doesn't know that his life is at stake
why doesn't he just wish them to fall
off or something I'm safe and an idiot
so he falls down some sort of secret
chute as he comes across I don't know
but they provide a way for Bastian to
talk to the childlike Empress we need
your dreams and stories do exist but the
people in your world no longer believe
in us they have no time to give us names
and stories I play violent video games a
reality TV only you can save us Bastian
you and my last phone help me obi-wan
Kenobi
so it turns out that she not only has to
find the evil but he also has to name it
in order to destroy it the Empress is
being held prisoner and before we can
fight the force that is holding her I
must give it a name
well why don't you name it after your
mother like in the first film what was
her name again
yeah I call it that but luckily Atreyu
shows up to help Bastian eyes quest and
give them some cred they did pick a
Native American kid this time people
talk about a castle that looks like a
hand some say that's where the Giants
come from so that's where we should be
heading just don't ask this too good for
any swamps of despair my voice is
telematic depressive the home would
point of living his doggy shot by Dex
Sebastian gets the idea to wish up a
giant monster to go after the evil
castle that's or the backfires chasing
somebody say chase so they go after the
fire-breathing monstrosity as they
bravely love the stock footage from the
first film
[Music]
hey look at reassembly a lot taller and
white oh hey um just an idea here um why
don't you wish the fucking thing away in
fact why don't you wish all the bad guys
away
this makes no sense if he makes a way
she loses a memory yeah I got that but
why doesn't he just wish the memory
machine away they never say there's a
limitation so this movie should be over
in like two seconds can you just be like
I wish for our gun I wish for that
machine to disappear by
so the dragon is that by the evil castle
as they come across an old familiar
friend the right fighter and son don't
ask details about how we reproduce let's
just say I should use rock control
meanwhile in the real world Baskin is
missing and his father goes looking for
him at the bookshop I found this book in
my son's room
it has your address inside the cover
where I saw it there myself last night
look we just sell mug wise and frogurt
anything else isn't my department
maybe when did you last see him maybe
you'll find the explanation for your
son's disappearance
inside inside my truck he's quite the
wall fighter a target so Atreyu meets up
with Bastian as they tried to figure out
a way inside the fortress so that's the
plan three arrows that's your plan yeah
Napoleon so kind of come up with
something better it's dangerous but it
just might work the second error looks
especially dangerous so they try
sneaking into the castle although lasers
seem to be playing Missile Command but
Bastian gets caught in one of the beans
[Music]
you saved my life you are you yes but
you would have done the same for me
eight right sure oh my god this kids a
dick is that really what you want to say
to your rescue one if someone said to
you from a burning fire would you be
like oh thank you so much just a heads
up if you were in the same situation
burning alive in a tall building I would
probably get pizza
nothing personal like just can't stand
your guts so the guards come out and
tried to stop them from entering the
castle this looks like a job for fabric
shades
so while this Mexican fiesta is going on
banjee manages to get inside but the
train was caught by the guards okay
seriously he's not wasting a wish to
save his best friend I see much I miss
at a skinhead rally we need weapons
I wish for that's the best you come up
like the last great dreamer or something
I all he can think of it's a fucking
break and the fantasies he thought up in
sidekicks were more impressive than this
in fact he should just watch the Chuck
Norris
they could turn everybody into ninjas
have a rocking battle everything will be
awesome
it means the coolest adventure ever but
no we get Frank an honest-to-god
frankenz I have no remorse with this
little idiot if something bad happens to
him
I am Sayid I admit defeat so you're the
one who makes everything empty I control
all that is empty just to control things
you destroy stories and books
sounds like the producers so she tells
them that she can release the childlike
Empress but only if she's closer to the
tower
so they take her as a prisoner to the
tower where they whoa what's up with
Falkor sighs there I am NOT going to
carry that woman what's he just like
that's by the devil for a second stick
your cock up her ass you motherfucking
worthless cocksucker so that your Brides
would say you'd end up pretty stupid
looking parade float as matching Stan
goes back to the bookstore only to find
everything's disappeared looks like
there hasn't been a bookstore here for a
long time so literally the books just
disappear because nobody's reading them
come on this isn't nearly as subtle as
the first movie that's like say my
Nintendo will disappear if I it's not
playing with it you'll stop the playing
with me enjoy your PlayStation three
cock maggot so while they're inside the
stained glass dreidel she starts to
convince Bastian that his prints are up
together in that she's the only person
he can trust
how can you believe her how can we even
be sure she's going to help us free the
childlike Empress I can tell when
someone lies to me I'm sure we can trust
a woman who listened too spidery Castle
has tried to kill us on several
occasions so she continues to turn
Bastion against his friends mostly
because he's stupid you're jealous
because I have Arne and you've come to
taken away from me every time you use
orange you lose one of your memories why
don't you just go back and play with
your Buffalo's culture boy didya wisher
so they both get in a fight and Bastian
tosses Atreyu off the rock
you ever notice a tree to a sort of a
shitty great warrior
but Bastian finds out what a prick he's
been Wayne sees everything a tree you
said was true unfortunately Falkor has
blown him away before Bastian could
apologize Bastian goes after him as his
father discovers that the book really is
alive and that bastions life hangs in
the balance
sayyida and her Giants drove through the
earth and into the underworld of
fantasia here they could travel with the
speed of darkness which was faster than
the speed of light bullshit they would
find Bastian in no time and force him to
make his last wish but luckily nimbly
has a change of heart as he tells batch
and how to get back behind those rocks
you'll find a path through the mountains
come with me he goes spies and flies
away who's the spy him over there yeah I
don't get it either
goodbye so Bastian makes it to Falkor
only to discover that a trio has little
to no life left I have two wishes left
Falkor you would have lost your most
precious memories my mother and my
father oh wait a minute he saw his
memories of Fantasia
he still has memories about how to talk
how could it be done those last two I
wish for nothing more in the world and
for you to live it's ray
well you got both wishes a trail is but
there's nothing more in the world good
but then sayyida finally shows up I
guess the speed of darkness is pretty
slow considering they just now caught up
with make your wish
yes Aida I will make my last wish I wish
for you to have a heart
drat I've been foiled by the power
no no it's it's cool what yeah yeah they
got taken care
ah man the one time I can use this
fucking thing it doesn't do sick so
because hearts apparently caused people
to explode Fantasia is back to normal
and the childlike Empress is set free
you have found the only wish powerful
enough to save us Bastian apart from I
wish Fantasia was saved why didn't you
do that again but Bastian still has to
go home and unfortunately the only
doorway back is the eye line that's the
way home yes that's the only way
there's also the tunnel of fluffy
pillows but is being repainted so
Bastion makes his leap of faith and
finally returns home
[Music]
the only upside in any of this is that
while the credits roll I get to hear
that kick-ass song
[Music]
you couldn't even give me the entire
song oh you have asked no time shit in
fact everything about this movie is
half-assed
the story is not interesting the message
is taken way too literally and of course
the logic just makes no sense why would
a kid who can wish for anything wish for
nothing
he has the powers of a god and what does
he fucking write for a god dance break
ham this movie is bullshit from
beginning to end but on a happy note I
am very satisfied that this is the very
last neverending story movie they never
made another dad awful sequel that I
would have to
let's pray